brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hi guys i'm lucy and
welcome to a slightly unusual episode of
reality check brought to you this week
by our friends at total war war hammer
they say history is written by the
victors the Romans the Allies and in the
case of the Battle of Waterloo the Duke
of Wellington not so good for his
opponent the actually average size for
the time Frenchman Napoleon Bonaparte
who after his defeat ended up being
exiled and losing everything he'd ever
worked for admittedly he was exiled to a
tropical island but he still died pretty
miserably so I got thinking what would
happen in an alternate version of the
Battle of Waterloo what if Napoleon's
men hadn't been defeated what if
Napoleon's men weren't men at all
instead what if Napoleon had orcs
so before we delve into our reimagine
Battle of Waterloo let's have a brief
history lesson to find out why it was
even happening at all in the early 1800s
Napoleon Bonaparte had quite the career
a military man who'd risen up through
the ranks of the French army eventually
seizing control of the entire country in
a bloodless coup d'etat being a
brilliant military tactician the now
Emperor Bonaparte managed to conquer
much of Europe but he got a little
big-headed and fell victim to one of the
classic blunders getting involved in a
land war in Russia it didn't go very
well and he was stripped of his rank and
exiled for about a year before coming
back and resuming power so naturally the
first thing you wanted to do was try and
take over the rest of Europe which
obviously annoyed everyone else so the
British prussians Russians and Austrians
ended up banding together to take him
down a couple of days before Waterloo on
june sixteenth 1985 Napoleon's troops
managed to force the Prussians into
retreating at the Battle of lynnie which
meant that they weren't present for
Waterloo released at the very beginning
so when the stage for the Battle of
Waterloo was set with Wellington's
68,000 men obviously minus the Prussians
who were on their way versus Napoleon's
72,000 so already Napoleon had the
numbers but he made a couple of critical
errors in judgment when leading his
troops and ended up losing which is
pretty much where his story ends however
I find alternate history stories like
the man in the high castle really
interesting and i'm also a big fantasy
nut so I enlisted the help of senior
games designer Richard Aldridge from the
Creative Assembly to let me know what
would actually happen to Waterloo if
there had been orcs in the equation
instead well let's start how humans and
orcs differ I mean hopefully we should
all have some first-hand experience with
how humans behave but what are orcs do
in their day-to-day lives I just fired
you know that is what I lost an aux life
is all about they wake up in the morning
and then one out got there and start
smashing stuff up or smashing people up
and if you know if there's nobody to
fight you know they will start fighting
themselves
this has been really isn't their forte
they really want to be fighting and you
know if this teeth or some loot at the
end of it yes you can sort of get them
to go and do your bidding but then they
pretty much want to do what they want to
do
we know that the armies in the early
1800s held some quite sophisticated
weaponry they were armed with muskets
which were lethal at several hundred
yards but inaccurate they had bayonets
were stabbing slow reloading rifles
cannons and of course swords although
all of the above might require a little
bit too much dexterity for our pals to
be able to use I don't think so I think
their hands are too big for one thing
they loot they pillage they still staff
babe you know they buying stuff together
they're currently looking for a sharp
pointy spiky rusty things and then
sticking them all together and that's
what you sort of get with their chariots
and think things of that nature trying
to find a way to make odd weapons
include crude weapons admittedly the
most sophisticated projectile that orcs
have is firing a small Goblin out of a
cannon
so there may be a little bit behind in
terms of advanced weaponry but you can't
fault them for strength and endurance
they are tough they're not the quickest
they certainly are not the brightest
either so you know they do somewhat
follow each other a little bit i guess
like sheep but yeah they're ferocious I
mean there then want for violence
basically just keeps keys and driving on
and its really only if you know a large
proportion and you know falling by the
way so I would I pop it out of that
battle and the fact that they have
access to supernatural powers definitely
works in their favor you've got goblin
shame and you've also got auctioning now
goblin shame and they specialize in the
law of little one that's different so
they got different spells York they
specialize in the law of the big wha it
do worship walk and more they're there
to orc gods and they got some pretty
cool things you know they call upon walk
and Mork where one of the spells that
they have literally gets a gorgeous slab
his foot down and crush people
underneath it
and then likewise for the Goblin in a
little while we may also look towards
the chaos moon as well so we had the
curse of the bad bad moon which can do
some pretty horrific damage to people
have conjured up but back to Waterloo
Napoleon made a crucial mistake which
ended up costing him the battle it had
rained the night before making the
battlefield or muddy and waterlogged so
instead of attacking at the crack of
dawn he made his troops wait until after
midday this was so the ground could dry
which was a good idea in theory but
sadly this did give the Prussians time
to get to the battlefield there was
about 30,000 prussians when they arrived
the outnumbered French began to flee but
if Napoleon had been commanding aux rich
thinks they might have fared a little
better with the waterlogged battlefield
they'll wait for it they'll put up don't
put up with it but it's not really part
and pastor then they come from a very
arid dry place in in in the old world so
yeah if they have to get their toe toe
where I guess they will but my our
choice I don't think they often go for a
dip they're pretty stinky so the orcs
might have been able to secure a victory
for Napoleon after all but then at the
end of the day once all the fighting was
over wouldn'ta Polian be able to keep a
grip on his green army may be quite a
bloody massacre I think he'd put up a
good fight valiant attempt I think he
ought to come out on top I do wonder
what would have happened to history if
Napoleon had one at Waterloo whereas
British folk all be speaking in French
or would the Allies have banded together
once again and taking him out for good I
hope you enjoyed this slightly more
irreverent look at history let me know
in the comments below thank you for
watching this week's episode of reality
check don't forget i'm on twitter alesi
james games for more make sure you keep
your eyes peeled to gamespot com